I'm just seeing headlines out of cow bio
that Martin shkreli has been terminated
as their CEO as well this was the other
well that was he the CEO or what's he on
their board the CEO in fact the
deal-breaker headline from November when
he was made CEO says desperate
pharmaceutical company hits rock bottom
named shkreli as CEO so I think it's
interesting I mean he served it all of a
month as CEO there it's it's now over is
he again this is a publicly traded
company right it wasn't it is a publicly
traded company they halted the shares
last week after the shkreli news came
out and they dropped by 50% it's a penny
stock it's worth you know 50 million
dollars after that drop same press
release there's also a board member
resigning from his position I mean it
seems like people don't want to touch
this toxic situation what's that gonna
do to the stock I just recommend reading
there's a hip-hop journal that had an
interview with him last week which I
thought was the most interesting
regarding his acquisition of the wu-tang
he has beef with RZA you know he does he
threatened RZA that he and his entire
Albanian sort of the all of the Albanian
immigrants together hold on his beef
with RZA he bought Kurt Cobain's credit
card just so he could whip it out but a
lot of these things point to the fact
that is this someone that acts with any
possible risk management or mature
decision-making process one might say no
no what he really wants more than
anything is to be a producer